Okay, ladies,
I'm gonna tell you something
that the rest of the world won't.
You don't need to have a hoe phase.
I got a DM from a girl that's kind of like my age,
and she asked me if I thought that that was, like,
a necessary part of life.
All her friends are telling her, like,
this is the time of your life to, like,
sleep around,
be promiscuous,
not get emotionally attached to guys,
just, like, hop around from one guy to the next.
And she's like,
am I. Do I need to do this?
Um, my opinion is no,
nobody needs to do that.
In fact, I think there are a lot of downsides
to the whole hookup culture in general,
and this idea that before you can settle down,
you need to,
like, go crazy.
And I think it's really ironic that the, like,
postmodern feminist movement right now
kind of seems to be pushing this idea of
like, you know,
women should be promiscuous and like,
cause it, you know,
makes them feel more, like,
equal to men.
I don't think that that's true.
I think that hookup culture,
according to the studies that I've looked up,
um, harms women,
and it doesn't fulfill what women really want.
It fulfills what toxic,
like, non committing men want,
but for women,
it usually, um,
doesn't do much.
Regarding hookups,
men and women
were both asked the same kind of questions,
and the reason for hookup
Regret for women was that they felt used a lot of times,
and they, um,
kind of regretted that.
And for men,
their biggest regret was that the woman they were with
wasn't attractive enough.
How is this empowering for women
to tell them to just go, like,
sleep with these kind of guys?
Like, that's not.
That's not empowerment, honey,
you don't need to do that.